hi there or should I say bonjour this is
Steve Kaufman here I'm going to talk
about how to learn french online and
specifically using the resources that
are available at link in my previous
video I showed you how to find content
in our library at link or from elsewhere
on the Internet
and I'm going to use three examples here
of how I would study now here is a
lesson and this is a lesson created by
two of our members immediately we see
that there are for me as a learner of
French although I'm not learning French
I have played around with French and
save certain words so what we see
immediately is that there are some words
that are highlighted in yellow and some
are blue and some are not highlighted at
all what that means is that the blue
words are new to me I may know them I
may not know them but I have not come
across them before at link if you are a
brand new learner at link all your words
will be blue once you save a word or
link it as we say it becomes yellow and
if you decide not to save a word you can
mark it as known individually like here
you can say known or you can click
linked and it will remove all of the
blue words that you did not link all
right so this is kind of the fundamental
task at link it's it's a way of adding
words to your database of words that you
want to learn it's indicating the words
that you already know and you set
yourselves self up so that the next time
any of these yellow words show up you're
reminded that you once hooked them up
you're reminded of what they mean and so
forth okay very quickly here there are
some instructions we want you to read
and listen we want to link new words in
other words you know decide the words
you want to learn and click on them if
you have the time to submit some writing
and also speak to a tutor on the subject
of this lesson you'll notice that
there's a sound bar where we can listen
to this
exchange this set it Roger said let's
got you slippin
wait just super questionable okay this
is a relatively simple conversation it's
natural it's unscripted the advantage of
this lesson is that it contains a lot of
relatively common words one of my
beliefs is that the sooner we can get
away from uninteresting beginner content
the better and this kind of conversation
generally has fewer difficult words in
it than let's say literature so it's a
very good place to start you don't need
to begin with very simple material and
and think that you are building this
great house based on building blocks or
that you've got some great foundation in
the language because in fact everything
we learned we forget and it's very
difficult to make interesting content
containing only the most common words in
the language and so forth so you're
better off to struggle through with
content that's a little difficult
linking listen more than once and even
if you don't fully understand it you
move on to the next now if I were doing
this lesson okay come on voila s good to
say pourquoi papel now you can save tap
L calling you as a word or maybe you're
more interested in ESCA to say pourquoi
shut up L you might be interested in
this whole phrase so then why I call you
so you have a choice you can either save
an individual word or you can sell if I
say the phrase alright so one thing by
the way as you save these these are
added to your list of Link's for this
lesson you can always go in and
flashcard them do close tests print them
export them to your Anki or whatever the
case may be you probably don't need to
look at this either once you're done
with it
so now you have a better look at this
text now normally if I were studying a
language I would say hmm there's not
that many new words here it might be
more convenient to do this on my iPad so
maybe I want to go through
and and get rid of all of the blue words
that I need to know
so my pal call me yeah I know that's
your peas I know that podcast I know
that act AXA is an emphasis yeah I made
like some emphasis okay so in other
words you're gonna go through here and
save these now and sometimes the
translation you know permit ray is would
permit so this translation that Google
Translate has provided is not very good
so in that case you click on search the
dictionary and allow would allow so you
grab that verb would allow permit a you
may or may not know that it's would
allow sometimes you'd say you just make
say allow because some of the call that
the functions of the word the grammar is
gonna gradually get clearer and then you
just save it all right so I would go
through and do that getting rid of all
my blue words now I'm not gonna do that
for you here but I would did that
because then I can read it I can read it
on my on my iPad and I'll have all the
words that I need the other thing that I
could do here is you know I regularly
you know like Sookie permit hey Sookie
perimeter that's the you know the
conditional you know it would permit
alright so I might want to save that and
you see they've got it wrong it's which
would permit so I would edit that and I
would say you know that is which would
permit and then I would also add a tag
and now I haven't got or maybe I have a
conditional all right so I would I would
tag that as conditional because then
later on in the vocab section I can
review a long list of examples of the
conditional if there might be other
expressions here or other you know gem
okay here's another conditional so you
know what I hear this is quite
interesting Jim I could put gem hi comet
up one
so I go and save that as a phrase and
see what they I would like to put the
point now that is wrong now Google
Translate tries it's best if it doesn't
come out quite correct you may ask your
tutor what does this mean or really what
this means is I would like to comment I
would I I would like them to you know
create or metal points to to to create
something right I would like and I might
tag that for their conditional and if
I'm really clever
I might tag it also for the um what do
you call it subjunctive which I don't
have here so I add that and I'm gonna
have another tag because they're Michael
meta J Michael MIT is actually the
subjunctive no I and you know that gets
pretty complicated and if you don't know
that didn't you don't know that but this
way you can tag two tags so that when
you find you know you can review all
your subjunctive
granted this assumes a certain knowledge
of the language so you kind of grow with
the system at first you don't tag for
that you probably have a little book
with some grammar explanations or you've
asked your tutor you get a sense of what
the subjunctive is and and and as you
become familiar with it you start
tagging for it or you might tag for you
know like just say say is savoir savvy
vu if you have trouble with that verb or
the verb of Wow Jeb was a vane news ever
or I'll Avon you may tag it as the verb
you know I'll a or however you want to
use the tags I find it quite useful to
do so you know that's kind of the main
thing here this is I think fun it's not
very difficult it's for an intermediate
learner if you're beginning in French
there are a lot of very basic beginner
lessons that you can spend a month or
two on but within a month or two you
should be moving on to these lessons no
let's move on here the other day I went
to Lamar
and I showed you how you can use our
bookmarklet to go and cut and paste and
bring articles in from from the
newspapers that are available on the
Internet and so here of course there are
more words that are new because the
newspaper uses more complicated a
vocabulary so I like to do a lot of
reading without the sound you'll notice
that there's no there's no sound bar
here because this was just a newspaper
article that we imported so voila I'm
Costa okay so you put your lips put your
cursor there and here is an observation
and here you have a number of
recommended you know hints or meanings
that our learners have chosen in the
past you may not be sure which one it is
which one applies in here and I always
say don't worry about the dictionary
definition you want to get a hint as to
what the meaning is if you have a few
hints after a while you start to piece
together what the meaning of this
article is and it may still be a bit
fuzzy I think it's very important that
language learners accept the fact that
meaning any meaning and anything they're
reading in the language is going to be
unclear for a long long time and they
should move on to new material even
though what they're working with is
little unclear it's not a matter of
nailing it down and putting bricks or
putting together a foundation it's a
matter of of exposing yourself and
someone on my youtube-channel said
quoting Michael Lewis with his lexical
approach to language learning language
learning is not a machine with
components language learning is like a
tree that you nourish with with you know
sunlight and and and water and and and
soil the nutrients and so forth so we
might just take that keep a de vache
upset sure so you know here again I
could go to the quick link view here a
good thing to do is to do the quick link
view to get through all of these new
words it's not that long a lesson an
article then go back in and save phrases
for specific points of grammar that you
want and now you're set to go on your
iPad where you can sit down in a
comfortable chair
and and read it again and if they're
sound on the iPad you can listen to the
sound and read it and with your finger
touchscreen just see the meanings of the
words so just moving on a little more
quickly here because I know there's a
time limit here is a audiobook so here's
the kind of stuff that's available all
this this is from our link library it's
ji de Maupassant Luo la from leave off
on which they kindly allowed us to put
up and so we can listen here hola rebei
Cal Julie admirable as if I see to
climate in a it notice your lab devanam
ISM sueleen on the platen now one of the
things you can do with a novel like this
which which may have a lot of new words
for you you can again go through and you
know save the words that you need and
then if you can them as I say read it on
your iPad or if you prefer and if you
have a hard copy you can actually read
the book and have adjacent all of the
words you need so that you can enjoy
reading the book the advantage of
reading on the iPad is you can also
listen to it so there's so many
different ways that you can access this
material you can listen to it on an mp3
player while running and I often do this
and of course I miss so much then I come
back to the book and I have my iPad
handy with the meanings of the words
available at the touch of a finger and I
read the book in paper which is a more
comfortable format and then so every so
often I will review the the words that
I've saved the list here is short if I
went through here and saved all the
words I needed the list would get longer
and I think that's enough today on the
subject of how I study these lessons and
next time I'll talk about how I would
deal with them in the vocabulary section
in order to have a better chance of of
remembering the words so that's that and
thank you very much for listening